all right so here's the thing 48 hours
ago we found something quite remarkable
what they find there's a structure in
Antarctica and especially really the
thing stars mary elizabeth winstead joel
edgerton and a whole bunch of different
people including the guy who imitated
Jim Carrey and dumb and Dumberer
Eric Christian Olsen I believe is his
name it's written by a guy whose name I
can't pronounce something something I
don't know now a lot of people are like
it says a remake is a prequel this is a
sequel what is this
it is a prequel this tells the story of
how the thing was first discovered what
led to what happens in the Kurt Russell
version this is Kate Lloyd's Columbia
Pell ontology let me show you why you
threw 10,000 bucks
we estimate this being here 100,000
years I've seen the 1951 version which
was called the thing from another world
and I saw that when I was like six my
mom introduced me to that film for some
reason I remember why she was like here
Chris watch this movie I was a little
boy it's like Luther think about another
way yeah and then I saw the thing with
Kurt Russell on the sci-fi channel I
think when I was a little bit older and
so I was kind of excited for this movie
yeah you know it's for those movies
where it could honestly be horrible like
it could just be really bad and then it
could be one of those movies way it's
fun and you expand you're like you know
what that actually wasn't that bad this
is just the year of surprises for me
Fast Five real steel a lot of movies are
really surprising this year and this one
did - I really like this movie I'm
serious I really dug this movie it was a
lot of fun
I'm always growing up in a you know
Jurassic Park jaws creature movies
monster movies and they're fun sometimes
sometimes they can be horrible sometimes
they can be a lot of fun and write this
movie knows what a creature movie is it
knows what it's supposed to do it's
nothing absolutely remarkable in regards
to storytelling it's just a group of
isolated people in a small place who are
starting to turn on one another because
there's this virus that's jumping
between people there's a lot of suspense
in that when these people aren't sure
they can't really work together as a
team because they don't know who is what
it creates for a lot of suspense and
there is some serious nail-biting scenes
in this movie just really suspenseful
tension I was really surprised my god
somebody was attacked but it seems
everyone is fine either someone
miraculously healed themselves or
someone is not who they say they are
I've seen so many suspense films like
this this one just had really actually
scared me a lot I was very surprised
some of the CGI is a little sketchy at
parts but for the most part I thought it
was very impressive
I do like practical effects more and so
in that way I live a 1982 version more
because I do like practical effects more
than CGI and there is some really good
practical effects in this film there's
some very good props but there's a
little bit too much CGI I think but
other than that I didn't really have too
much problems many of the things that
happen in regards to the creatures that
were created with the various forms this
thing takes
what was it doing to him it's how much
eating his cells I think this thing
copies its prey and then hides inside I
really liked mary elizabeth winstead
this member you know she's from scott
pilgrim she kind of got her start with
these kind of movies like with final
destination three none of it was too
jumpy at all it was very well filmed it
all looked really nice some of the the
scenery outside of Antarctica was
breathtaking
I liked Marco Beltrami score a lot
attributed to the original score by
Ennio Morricone in just the right ways
but it also created its own style as
well I love scary creature movies and I
love movies where a group people are
isolated and they have to deal with a
problem in it it had a lot of good
tension you felt really like you were
there I'm gonna give the thing in a -
not all of us are human could be any of
us there's a few times in the acting was
a little bit over the top a little bit
over use of CGI at times a couple times
or relied on jump scares but for the
most part the scares in this movie were
genuine and that's what I really liked I
enjoyed it a lot it's a good monster
movie so yeah the thing what do you know
so if you liked my review can subscribe
to my channel and get stuck mine eyes